زياره هي الاولى للسلطان عمان هيثم بن
طارق الى ايران زياره رسميه تعكس طبيعه
العلاقات بين طهران ومسقط
تاتي اهميتها من حيث توقيتها والاوضاع
التي تشهدها المنطقه وفي اشاره الى اهميه
الزياره وزير الخارجيه للايراني حسين امير
عبد الله كان قد صرح في وقت سابق بان
السلطان سياتي الى طهران محملا بخبر جيد
هو ما قرئ بان مضمون الخبر يتناول التفاوض
غير المباشر بين طهران و واشنطن تتجه
الانظار اذا نحو اللقاء بين سلطان عمان
والرئيس الايراني متوقعه ان يحمل انفراجه
في بعض الملفات العالقه لايران مع الخارج
ممتاز سلطنه عمان لها مكانه خاصه في
السياسه الخارجيه لايران فدور عمان في
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه ايجابي نشكر
جلاله السلطان على جهوده البناءه في
الشؤون الاقليميه والدوليه وكما
تحدث الزعيمان سوف نستمر معالي الوزير في
تواصلنا
ومشاوراتنا وتعاوننا في كل ما من شانه
معالجه وايجاد الحلول السلميه لكثير من
القضايا والتطورات وان نتشارك كمجموعه
اقليميه بروح بناءه دائما في هذا المسعى
ان شاء الله
سلطنه عمان حاضره في ملف عوده العلاقات
بين ايران والسعوديه وحديث اليوم عن سعي
عماني لتقريب وجهات النظر بين ايران ودول
اخرى في المنطقه
زياره سلطان عمان الى ايران ترتبط في جزء
منها بملفات المنطقه ويمكن عن طريقها حل
بعض المشاكل العالقه لايران مع بعض دول
المنطقه
الثنائيه عن محور الزياره ان لم تكن هي
الاساس فالطرفان يسعيان لتكميل مشروع
تصدير الغاز الايراني الى عمان ويبحثان عن
رفع قيمه التبادل التجاري الى ثلاثه
مليارات دولار بعدما وصلت السنه الماضيه
الى مليار وثمانمائه الف دولار جرت العاده
عند وصول اي مسؤول عماني الى ايران ان
تتجهل انظاره الى ما يمكن ان يحمله من
رسائل اليها وهناك من يترقب اليوم بعد
زياره سلطان عمان لايران ملفات عالقه
لطهران اقليميا ودوليا نوردين غير الجزيره
طهران